foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another phenomenal
episode of the careful boys and today
we're going to request that Canada Nick
switch ceased real quick yes yes
this is what happened in my dream yeah
oh it happened in his dream Nick's
hosting what happens next and then you
put the Shockers in his hands oh we do
no Shockers bro why is your chair so
high put it in I like oh [__]
you never put a fist near a butthole oh
chill bro just chill
chill wow I am alive I don't like
sitting here man why am I saying can you
just relax for a second my heart's
beating on my [__] chest it looks
really cool though yeah you look so cool
look at my heart rate because I'm
wearing barbell Brigade merch off the
record time it's time to talk about us
media I don't want to talk about it yeah
and then he remembered he should talk
about it it's weird because yeah we were
sharing that what's that about yeah what
is that so it's just martial arts media
company that my friend Gilbert and a
really cool guy Ben Carpenter started or
it's a marshall it's like you guys ever
heard of donut media knows guys for cars
for cars but they're doing we're gonna
do it for martial arts oh I think I met
him at the licensing Expo oh really yeah
that's cool dude dude I love Gilbert
Gilbert's the man yeah it makes one of
them Gilbert's okay Gilbert's all right
yeah does he make me mad sometimes yeah
he makes me mad but I love him Gilbert
has made you mad before oh dude he makes
me mad all the time yeah like a
seriously and he knows no way yeah I
know why I know why because he's never
on time
sometimes that and sometimes sometimes
he sometimes he shows up and then we're
like what are you doing and he's like I
thought I'm supposed to be JK today I'm
like why
or sometimes you'll be like hey I'm at
the office and we're like we're not
there he goes I thought I was supposed
to film with you guys and I'm like
I don't know who told you that yeah you
want to kill him sometimes how does that
happen to him kilbert uh it makes me
want to grab him by his neck I just
yeah
no but sometimes I'll text Gilbert and
he just won't text me back for like days
I'm gonna be like sorry man what's up
and I'm like forget it and he takes me
back yeah because he has to text you
back yeah but then to me he just treats
me like [__] and he does that to
everybody too oh it makes me want to
slit his throat not me full serious so
what's the deal with uh
they brought you one as a host as a host
that's sick purely because of my ears
because you're funny because they said
it would get it would make it seem like
because I have these ears I know what
I'm talking about but really I know
so the more [__] up someone looks the
more that they'll so if I get a couple
black eyes
I'll come in with a scar on my face dude
that's too badass yeah then you look
like a Mortal Kombat character you look
like Raiden we all come deformed one day
someone punched me so hard that my skin
started peeling out this way so I had to
get it pulled back and then scarred
scarf yeah that's a good identity as a
host yeah it's a really cool company
that it's like a startup
um but they asked me to help them create
some content it's cool to do it I mean
it's we have a really cool writer his
name is Nate he writes all the um he's
good yeah he's really good he's the one
that writes all the scripts and then I
just read it and I go the the the the
like that so in that video there's like
a Dustin Poirier video with where he
he's like narrowing the whole thing and
uh you said
that in the real thing you stuttered a
lot oh yeah for sure
but in that video it just seems so
comfortable so smooth
you got a lot of practice here and JK
gave you a chance bro honestly it does
it all this no for real though like like
being in front of the camera like this
at first it's weird talking it's still
weird talking in front of my camera but
it does get kind of easier
um is this good content probably not did
I edit did I edit that video I think you
edited a couple that's why I did a
couple ones I like that video too
because also you're it seems different
when you get to talk about something you
are interested in and you have a lot of
knowledge versus like hey Nick talk
about yourself yeah well it's just like
first off I don't know it's just kind of
weird is it about yourself huh is it
about yourself what do you mean no the
video No it's it's we're profiling
Fighters that happen to be fighting in
the UFC or boxing or whatever we just
highlight their story and talk about
like a unique take that we have on uh
what we think about them you know I
shared your story for you but then like
I didn't watch it that's why I'm asking
you were you what is that I shared it
for you I shared it but you didn't watch
it but I didn't watch it that's a true
friend though and I wouldn't I kind of
wouldn't want you to watch it I watched
just kidding it was I like I didn't
watch the whole video I watched The Reel
yeah you don't have to watch all the
time I watch the real
I thought it was it was good because
also I have zero interest in like who
this dude was and then I thought it was
really good yeah because I'm interested
in you
I watched your commentary about the
fight I forgot I was watching you
honestly really I really did that's good
that's good thank God
let me start screen recording because I
know he's gonna save him something dumb
fight clips yeah and then eventually I
was like oh that was actually just
really cool it's just cool because we
get to tell a story of you know Fighters
that we really enjoy that we really like
and so is that your role as a you're
just a fight common you're commenting on
what you see on the fights yeah pretty
much or scripted yeah scripted we work
on it for a while and then we kind of
would you like us to make a video like
that of of you yeah we could do that
we'll do that but it's about him all
right this is Nick we'll work on it and
you guys he's a new rookie we hand him
the script
but it's cool because like I'll be
standing in front of the camera and it's
it's hard to like because I have to
teleprompter [__] when we do it yeah and
then you have a telephone
yeah and they'll tell me to be like ah
don't say it like that punches in it
with like a little more spirit and
emotion should not say it like that
that's like that can you can you say
with a little more enthusiasm and I'll
be like oh well that's the hardest note
it's hard to me yeah more have more
energy is really difficult more energy
but authentic there's there's a there's
a commercial I did for Singapore back
when I was like I was like 23 or
something it was like a for a dance show
out there and they just kept asking me
over and over to like oh can you just
pick the energy up yeah and I was like
what the
[__] this [__] up but that's that's
such a general note I looked at it and I
looked hella tired I was like oh that's
a
I just thought it was energetic
but that's when it's good that we have a
convert I feel very thankful to work
with the guys that we have yeah because
they're really good at directing me and
telling me to like not [__] up or
whatever do you genuinely have fun when
you do it yeah but it's also like a
challenge too right because it's like
something new and
it's kind of hard and it's not really in
my skill set so it is interesting
hearing you talk about that stuff
because I have watched like when I was
like working on your video I was like oh
dude I get to see Nick in a different
show acting different you know
behaving very differently than you are
here I gotta be fake here yeah I would
say uh he's definitely more authentic
here than he is with that because yeah
oh that's true well it's scripted though
too exactly yeah it's scripted the vibe
of the other like if you watch any of
the donut content like they're they're
very in that so many cool cars yeah and
like the way they do all their content
is is kind of like at least the the up
to speed kind of yeah up to speed is
great that is very similar because it's
more like factual yeah and it's just
telling a story and it's just like the
editing to know about the Honda Prelude
yeah yeah you're just playing the part
of the host and you're speaking on it's
kind of weird it's kind of weird seeing
me do those videos are you guys gonna do
videos similar to Donut where they'll uh
review two products against each other
that's like the
we might do something like that we we
experiment so a little bit we'll see
what happens like it's a lot of it isn't
like the testing phase because it's
still so new and it's still early so
we'll see we'll see what happens we'll
see what happens do you have any ideas
yourself that you want them to do
um do you have any suggestions you want
to do a hospital video I only want to do
a hospital actually we're I think we'll
see but that's in the pipeline we'll see
really a hospital video you should just
make your own husband just get another
guy
make your own husband just like craft
one I'll make them in the lab just make
it has to build a competitor yeah it's
like from us that'd be tough dude yeah
um but yeah we'll see it's just weird
it's just kind of weird why because
you're on camera so much by yourself
yeah it's weird it's not the same like
this I feel safe here you know at first
I didn't if you feel dangerous there no
not even I just feel like oh there's a
lot of pressure please don't [__] it up
I just want to [__] up the video you
know if you had to choose either us or
JK to just completely die which one to
completely die
to fail as a channel
this is a test well honestly
I got my allegiance I'm not just saying
this
for my Legions
is with JK bro it better be [__] you
guys can't see he called me a [__]
you get paid more there over here
[Laughter]
um
it's here he's thinking about it let me
guess they gave you stock we're still a
startup
we're starting up so if it blows up
you're gonna bounce on us huh I think
there's a world I could do both you know
what I mean these never works
but it's like we've I do other [__]
besides this I have a regular job
outside yeah anybody you have to
you kind of have to yeah this schedule
and job is so easy anyone that stresses
all off of this you're freaking stupid
yeah row that's what I'm saying it's
like you we gotta make you can make it
work you can make it work especially
because we're all Freelancers too that's
just sometimes that's that's the best
part about it yeah if I had a nine to
five out of everyone this is the most uh
absent tardy boy here oh he's not tardy
he's very absent oh really still here
more days than Steve right but also but
also you got next to you because because
you're doing grand openings for hair
salons and car show and you keep getting
burnt flu you also know that I might be
near just as much as Bart is right oh
interesting white bar it has a lot of
absence dude he's not even here right
now I don't know but where's he at right
now competitions
I'm just throwing out stats no big deal
y'all
it is nice when you're here make me the
villain go ahead I don't know who Shades
these are go ahead those are cool Warby
Parker Fit you oh thank you Steve is
only here half of the time that everyone
else is here yeah but takes up twice the
space
he's alive
his bags
I just like the idea of him watching
this not being able to rebut with you
later
she's gonna be the comments meanwhile
she's sitting there [__] just eating
gingerbread noodles actually enjoying it
like a fan thank you Steve I think
Steve's your biggest fan he is
you can't see my eyes I can see your
eyes no one here drinks with them except
you include no it's I think if you
understand Steve's love language it's
drinking dead giveaway that he and he's
Anthony's biggest that's the way that
can talks about you isn't that a
coincidence but I actually hate him
though
oh you can't how about that I think you
guys love each other I don't really like
it no I don't see any love where's it at
you won't receive any for me dude I'm
not gonna give you anything I'm very
withholding I can be very cold if I want
to
so
what'd you think about the uh Jake Paul
nadius fight yeah it was a fun fight bro
wasn't it did you guys watch it no you
saw the clips who is that I was busy
with my other I was watching it on the
phone a lot of people thought finally it
was Nate Diaz that was gonna take him
down and then what didn't happen Jake's
really good at picking fights for
himself right it's not like saying that
he beat a chump in Nate Diaz because
Nadia is not a sharp he's a [__]
beast but also every time you see Jake
Paul fight you're like man this dude is
he's putting in the work he's getting
better that's why he's beating all these
guys is that legit KO the knockdown yeah
it was it was it was because he hit him
on the temple kind of makes you all
wobble oh no so it's like it's it's
reasonable for him to fall like that and
Jake's a bigger guy I think too like
naturally yeah people are talking about
uh
MMA now as a rematch yeah I don't know
how that's gonna happen I don't know I'm
sure if
I think the other thing about Jake Paul
too is like we continue to doubt him in
the sport his ability to sell
pay-per-views the way he has and he he's
been exceeding expectations every time
so he deserves a lot more credit than
he's getting it wow coming from a
fighter that's all that means a lot of
respect I think yeah we're probably
gonna do a video on Jake Paul yes that
fight kind of made me a fan honestly I
was rooting for Nate Diaz do you think a
lot of Fighters their ideas are changing
about him because I feel like there's so
many people that are yeah they have to
because he's Mo he's like he's starting
to get some legit play I think you kind
of sound silly the longer you're like
hey and it's just like
he's bringing more eyes to the sport
he's it's just it's a net positive
overall I think because how many people
are talking about him when I first
started doing MMA or anything like that
to see it the way it's blown up now is
so insane the fact that Mark Zuckerberg
is talking about doing [__] he does
right Elon Musk like this [__] is wild
are you gonna do a video about that
about analyzing the logistics between
the two of them potentially yeah we're
talking about doing something like that
we'll see what happens we'll see but I
think that's something we can do it'll
be fun but our last video game
go watch it wait which video is that
dude is a Sean O'Malley one this is what
I like I like everything that's the
newest video that's the newest one I
don't even know that it's because we
didn't promote it for you guys no it's
fine
um well I think the uh the channel
initially started it got a lot of pop
because of
the guys also that work on the channel
the other side is the uh the stunt side
and we have some really cool guys from
8711 Jeremy marinas yeah Jeremy's dope
he did all the John Wick movies he'll do
any action movie you'll see he's the the
main guy in it he gets killed in John
Wick for like eight different times
yeah yeah so he he's on the other side
of the stunt stuff and I guess the big
pop that they got on the channel was
from the John Wick inside behind the
scenes like one of the videos got like
100k like pretty cool hell yeah and I
think a lot of the subscribers are
mostly in the stunt scenes oh so because
so many anime stuff so it'll take some
time but we're still just testing stuff
out right tips for building a YouTube
channel
nah
no nothing
um have a smaller cast so there's more
money going around yeah we're pretty
small okay dude we're pretty small cat
what else is there what else what else
we got dude probably pay people really
low to start with we're doing that so
you don't you set them out really low I
think just stop uploading for like weeks
do it inconsistently come back
make sure can doesn't delete your
footage
no you have to delete it you gotta
delete it you gotta start fresh yeah you
gotta Rebrand and [__]
but um make sure you guys have a Reddit
dedicated just hating
That's What Makes You legit yeah yeah we
don't have haters everyone's very
supportive I don't like that's why I'm
like you gotta get some people to hate
you guys a little bit right here yeah
well I think it's already it's hey go
hate on the videos y'all go hate on the
video but you know what is cool is that
the JK fans do love to support you and
they are there too yeah to see people uh
commenting on it and saying oh like it
just it's it's very nice everyone's very
nice that's so nice thank you JK fans
for supporting Nick
thanks for just letting me you have a
vision for where you want to take that
um yeah well I hope we can just keep
making cool videos that people like
that's the main thing what's the goal to
like to to to have a different
perspective on the fight scene or
well
I think for us we've been covering a
little bit more of
I think highlighting the fighters a
little bit more rather than and it's
kind of showing
the behind the scenes on what the
fighter like mentality wise
business-wise the things that they have
to do to push fights to make it bigger
like if you guys watch the channel
malify you'll kind of see where that
comes from because he's kind of a very
polarizing fighter that no one really
people either really like him or they're
like he [__] sucks he doesn't deserve
to fight for the title whatever all the
criticisms so we like to have a little
bit of a unique take and just take both
sides of it and oh so you're more of the
neutral not really neutral I like the
lighthearted tone of it yeah we try to
keep it light-hearted it makes it more
watchable to someone like me that's not
inherently interested in it we wanted
the ultimate casual [__] viewing
experience you could be like if you want
to do it super casual you could just be
like look at the [__] size of the
knuckle on this guy look at the [__]
forehead he could take a punch like a
mother yeah yeah yeah yeah people relate
to that yeah
see how long his arms is look how big
his four it is dude look at that canvas
five head yeah yeah can you do a video
like that where you just kind of take
the script and like riff off of that or
would they be like no you can't see that
they'll be like that's not the
teleprompter I don't know I'll ride it
but also too like watching how like
working with our Rider Nate seeing how
he composes it that's a really cool
thing is like taking a point or or just
crafting like a video essay type of
thing
um and it is it is hard it's a lot of
work right to see how the writers
simplify it and give me give me a
fighter I'll give you a profile all
right let's do Conor McGregor bro all
right look at this guy you see him and
you you know you know Ginger's got a
[__] chip on her shoulder because
everyone calls him Solas and [__]
piece of [__] so he grew up ready to
murder [__] and look at him
he's Irish a lot of people that are
Irish they're connected to Crime so you
know he's down for his [__] he'll [__]
you up you see that walk looking like a
mini baby gorilla coming into the stage
because he's mentally prepared to come
into the scene and [__] you up like an
animal he's not afraid yeah yeah do you
want a job
switches places with Nick I like the
look of this guy
this guy look at this [__] guy it's a
great way to start a video yeah look at
this guy you see the last time he he
used his brains literally to knock that
dude out he went straight from the
shoulder he said hiya I think how long
does one uh shoot take for you guys like
if you're gonna do a dust Emporia shoot
like how long did it take beginning to
end
uh that probably took us maybe an hour
it's too long an hour too long are you
kidding but it's also like it's short
it's short an hour but I think it was
just because we're
guys the screen yeah yeah the script's
ready to go just like what changing
tones that's what it's like yeah okay
that's really fast this is like a couple
different takes with like jokes or
something or they'll make me say things
over and over again an hour dude that's
that's the hardest part is like they'll
be like hey try this joke again and I'll
be like all right but it's not funny
anymore after the test yeah yeah yeah
yeah but then when they put in the edit
it does kind of okay cool like you you
see how the editor works huh you laugh
at yourself
I don't even watch it like Gilbert will
send me a clip like late at night hey
check out the intro and I just won't
respond says the guy who complained
about Gilbert not responding to your
test for days I'll text them the next
morning and I'll watch like the first 10
seconds of it and I'll be like haha LOL
sick and I'll just send that back to him
what a liar dude but it's he knows he
knows I'm a [__] head case dude I
don't want to watch it you guys are
meant for each other man yeah yeah but
yeah we'll see what happens what's media
thanks for doing this video thanks yeah
everybody go watch Nick stuff and then
make sure you give them all the hate
that you can because he needs that do
what you cut the cameras before you do
what you guys are already doing do what
you guys are already doing go on the
thing and talk about how funny he is I
don't like that dude it makes me feel
like it's a bit and it is it's true Nick
and I did talk about this it's not a bit
dude oh yeah me and Colleen had a
separate conversation about this
okay